what do you think about just stop oil
going on to the pitch at Lords
I think a lot of people are losing
sympathy with them because of the way
that they're behaving the other day they
had this big protest disrupting stuff
outside a hospital potentially
endangering people's lives it's not the
first time that they've done that and
now this disruption that the cricket as
well I don't think they're doing the
environmental movement any favors at all
because I think that people just will
see that this is unreasonable behavior
in some cases endangering people's lives
tell me about this health check that I'm
going to get in the post yeah so a few
years back we brought in the NHS health
check
um which is like a sort of Health mot
where we take people's blood tests we
take their blood pressure and we work
out if they're at risk of diseases and
it's been a big success and people who
do the health check are about half as
less likely to die of cardiovascular
disease as people who don't but the
problem is that only at the moment about
40 of people are doing it and so we're
bringing in a new digital version of it
to make it much more convenient for
people to do it where you'll be able to
enter a bunch of your details on your
phone or on the computer or into the NHS
app and then you'll be able to can do
that already though can't you yes so in
some places you can and I did that
myself when I did it the other day but
that's not everywhere and the thing you
can't do is I had to go into my GP
surgery to go and give blood in the
future as part of this digital check
you'll be able to do that in a
convenient way at home and be able to do
your blood pressure check and like a
local pharmacy and that will make it a
bit easier for people to do it so we
think that there will be another million
people get these potentially life-saving
checks as a result okay but it also free
up some time for GP so it frees up about
20 minutes of time in general practice
that means more appointments easy to get
through in it it builds on the other
things that we're doing like the
pharmacy first service that we're
bringing in at the end of the year in
just you know taking the pressure off of
GPS by enabling people to get care in a
really convenient way Thames waters on
life support what are you going to do
about that
so in the first instance this is still
something for the companies themselves
and their shareholders to sort out
looking less and less likely though
isn't it I I don't know I'm not privy to
the company's financial information but
of course we do have contingent papers
yeah I do I read the papers and I see
you in the papers this morning that they
are still in the process of um finding
uh further resources from their own
shareholders and that's the first place
they should look to obviously of course
the government does have contingency
plans if this does become what are they
a problem uh I I at this stage I I I'm
not able to say what we would do exactly
it would depend exactly on the
circumstances but the government would
take Thames water back into
um public control if needed because a
lot of people who are watching this
morning are customers of Thames water
and they're worrying about what's going
to happen next absolutely to reassure
them absolutely nothing is going to
happen in terms of either their bills or
their access to water we have
contingency plans like we do in all
these Network utilities to manage any
difficult situations so the government
would take that control as a last resort
we absolutely have contingency plans and
they won't take back it will not the
last resort be a problem it will depend
exactly what happens at the moment this
is still hypothetical because they are
probably other companies they're in the
process of raising my funds and off what
last year was taking action to improve
their financial resilience in fact the
debt to equity of the water industry as
a whole did fall last year so they have
been tightening the nut they have been
putting in new rules like you know you
can't uh make any kind of payments to
your uh uh uh
shareholders if you're not meeting
environmental criteria if you don't have
an investment grade credit rating so the
financial nut has been tightened on them
over the last year that has improved
their resilience but of course if there
is any problem we absolutely do have
contingency plans in place okay I read
in the paper this morning I think it's
in the times that four other companies
are also at water companies are also
being looked at by the government
because they're not as stable as they
should be
yeah so there's the speculation of
course all the time in markets when
there is concern about one company
there's always people ask questions
about other similar companies but as I
say there has been action uh deep into
last year to try and improve their
financial resilience and that some
extent has improved their financial
resilience
um
actually they're handing out billions
over a period of 20 years to their
shareholders and they've got all of this
debt that they can't finance and these
people who are shareholders let's it's
not just like ordinary people like you
and me it's people you know like the
Chinese involvement Abu Dhabi
involvement um Canadian government
involvement not government
um uh pensions involvement yeah so on
the other hand they have also made about
190 billion pounds worth of investment
and investment rates have been running
about twice the level they were
pre-privatization and what's been
happening soon so what's been happening
in recent years is we have discovered
and we have been exposing the problem
about these companies behaving badly and
dumping sewage into rivers when we came
to office only about seven percent of
these storm overflows were even being
monitored by the end of this year it'll
be a hundred percent and that is showing
up and exposing deliberately that they
have been behaving badly and as a result
of that we then pass and how they're
investing all this money and then on the
other hand how they're behaving the
reason they're investing all this money
is that we passed a piece of legislation
in 2021 we environment act which
committed them and made them invest 56
billion pounds in upgrading their
networks so that we end this problem
over the next 25 years they'll be
investing 56 billion and even now even
in this Parliament they're spending 3
billion and they will be cutting the
number of these overflows by a quarter
by the end of this Parliament by 2025.
let's just mop up on this Daniel Cross
Key thing he was going to be he hoped to
be the mayor on candidate for the
conservatives here in London uh he
stepped down yesterday was that the
right decision after this suggestion
that he'd been growing a woman that was
his decision
so the allegation where she he denies I
have to be quite careful because he
denies it Minister all my question is is
was he right on balance to have stepped
back yes thank you there we go straight
oh my goodness me can somebody log that
uh talk to me about the illegal
immigration Bill we hear about it again
uh in the courts today whoever wins or
whoever loses they can appeal will we
ever see any anybody sent to Rwanda yeah
so the small boats bill which we've
already passed through the commons is
currently in Lords and even last night
labor and lived in peers sabotaged one
of the most important things in it we
can sabotage it they just have their
voted they voted it down they're
perfectly entitled
but our view is we've got to stop small
bits and we've got to restore our
ability to deport people who shouldn't
be here some of whom are serious
criminals by the way and we uh through
this small builds Bill uh taking action
to take away that Thicket of August
rules and human rights laws that are
being used by all these people last
minute to stop themselves from being
deported that's what we're in favor of
it will stop the small boats it will
deter people from coming here it will
create a new Duty on the Home Secretary
to deport anyone who is here illegally
and indeed it makes it impossible to
claim Asylum if you come here illegally
I think it's totally the right piece of
legislation but in the Lords labor and
the lib Dems are fighting it tooth and
nail even though that is clearly what
most people in this country want people
want to see our borders strengthened
they want to see the small boat stopped
because it's not fair even for people
who've come here legally including my
constituents they've jumped through all
the Hoops they've played by the rules
and these people just forcing their way
in illegally risking their lives in many
cases supporting a criminal trade so
we've got to stop these small boats and
our piece of legislation will do that
but at the moment we are facing a lot of
resistance
yeah in the Lords and I hope we can
overcome those privileges committee
report Before I Let You Go it looks as
though potentially there'll be some
criticism of those that were uh not
necessarily using the right tactics in
in supporting the former prime minister
Boris Johnson uh we'll hear about it
probably about nine o'clock or
thereabouts likely to be criticism for
people like Nadine Doris uh Jacob Reese
smog Etc how damaging is this for you as
a party
so ultimately the Privileges committee
is a matter for their house the salesman
and then part the house had it say on
Monday it voted to support the report
and as a government obviously we are
focused on delivering the Behaving Badly
conservative MPS Behaving Badly again
well as a government we are totally
focused on getting on with the PM's
priorities of getting inflation down
cutting NHS waiting list but that is
what we're focused on rather than rather
than time we're having to focus that's
what you want us to focus on and
meantime I guess the focus on for the
public yeah and meantime again we're
talking about a toy MPS Behaving Badly
ultimately uh on boys Johnson the house
I did say the other day voted for the
censure he's now gone not just as prime
minister but as an MP and I I say this
as someone who who resigned because I
didn't think that things were being done
right during boris's uh time in office
he went as PM he's now gone as an MP But
ultimately we have to move on from all
the back and forth about Boris Johnson
we've got to focus on the issues of now
getting inflation down stopping the
small boats that we've just been talking
about because the NHS waiting lists
those are the things when I I'm on the
doorsteps that people ask me about
rather than the the umpteenth situation
of all this stuff well um I'll have to
see what happens at nine o'clock it's
always a pleasure Minister thanks very
much